[Musica]
a chi è bellissima giornata per un
campeggio fuori c'è caldo ma non troppo
che per fare buio e soprattutto non c'è
nessun pazzo che viene a disturbarmi no
berlino vi sono spaventata vita ma
quando entri nella tenda busta almeno mi
raccomando se non mi seguite ancora
studente g andati a seguirmi su
instagram e se volete andate a seguirmi
anche sui tic toc e provate a lasciare
un mi piace questo video in 5 secondi 5
4 3 2 1 o tempo scaduto ci siete
riusciti prendete i pop corn e iniziamo
pure questo campeggio al buio di notte
assieme ci sono dei rumori strani fuori
a no
chi sono merlino che sgranocchiare un
pezzo di albero controlliamo fuori dalla
finestra
non ho perso un giorno sono proprio i
cinque giorni come nel videogioco di g
quindi dobbiamo spiegarci perché
preferirei sconfiggere granny alla luce
che al buio via libera
usciamo e cerchiamo gli oggetti che
possono servirci per sconfiggere gremio
per scappare dentro casa
non è che mi aiuteresti mi aiuti a
trovare gli oggetti forse troppo si
basino centro quindi a far mangiare
questo diremo qualcosa sopra berlino
[Musica]
tarme non guardino lasciare la sala
ho dovuto rincorrere merlino per tutto
il giardino perché non voleva lasciare
il mercure voleva il grano chiave
distruggerlo con i suoi denti come ogni
cosa
sono molto contenta perché adesso un
qualcosa per difendermi da granny
continuiamo a esplorare a cercare altri
oggetti che c'è un arrivo i geni e lily
può essere li hanno solo una lucertola
[Applauso]
se mi ha visto
6 ha funzionato ho sconfitto g ce l'ho
fatta io purtroppo ho perso un'altra
vita pensavo che il nervo avesse
sconfitto grandi realtà la rallenta e
basta quindi devo stare molto attenta e
utilizzarlo solo per rallentarla mi
sembra di vedere qualcosa faccia
qualcosa di fatto che una cassetta è
visto berlino una cassetta rossa a cosa
servirà anche di questo
merito no no lascia la bravissima
che cosa vuol dire la paura dobbiamo
scappare fiorini berlino
non è proprio una porta e tipo un telo
spero che si allontani al più presto
nel frattempo devo capire cosa significa
questo disegno e tipo un gatto fatto di
tre angeli che cosa può voler dire
sicuramente un indizio per riuscire a
tornare dentro casa invenzioni terre
prove entrare dentro calda anche senza
risolvere gli enigmi ed indovinelli 6
riesco a entrare lo stesso non ho
bisogno di risolvere tutti gli
indovinelli grainy si rimarrebbe
malissimo o che proviamo in tali merlino
che stai facendo
marlin a stava prima macchiando il nervo
ovviamente non è di un tuo gioco berlino
lo so che i colori sembrano quelli dei
suoi giochini così il tuo giochini lo
siamo fuori dalla tenda si sono accese
le luci fuori
meno male almeno non sarà buio pesto
andiamo verso la porta di casa e spero
che sia aperta
ok magari è aperta vediamo questa è
aperta
no è chiusa
lei questa challenge si sta rivelando
molto più difficile del normale è sempre
un po difficile con treni ma è ancora
più difficile in campeggio
venite po per portare salvare questo
indovinello poi riusciti a capire cosa
può voler dire
nel frattempo che i treni e da quella
parte io provo andare a vedere che cos'è
la cassetta rossa magari c'è qualche
indizio la chiave che non è un lucchetto
con una chiave è un lucchetto con i
numeri è visto merlino no inutile che
non è chi non si apre solo le grazie
dell'aiuto berlino ma non funziona
quindi vuol dire che devo trovare la
giusta combinazione prova a mettere un
numero a caldo succede niente ho capito
quindi quell'immagine nasconde in realtà
il numero della combinazione del
lucchetto per aprire questa cassetta
devo riuscire a capire subito quale il
numero sono qua con il mio indovino e lo
sto cercando di capire quale potrebbe
essere il numero nascosto qui ma non mi
viene in mente niente
è meglio usare lo sento ok ma ci sono
aziende che si siamo più al sicuro
comunque l'unico numero che potrebbe
essere associato a gremire il 1900 la
sua data di nascita spacco non si
arrabbi
forse mi ha sentito no grain intendevo
dire che se i giovani stima sei nata nel
icy notato che questo gatto è formato
solamente da triangoli forse devo
contare i triangoli e quello sarà il
numero del lucchetto un triangolo e la
testa due sono le orecchie quindi 123
qua negli occhi due triangoli ciascuno
quindi 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
non sono sicura se contare anche questi
due piccoli triangolini spero di sì
penso che il numero sia 16 ora non ci
resta che andare a provare vediamo che
grandi civiltà qualcuno qua
non vedo nessuno
[Applauso]
o tu camilli che si sta vicino allo zero
ci sono tre cifre quindi immagino che la
prima sia 2009 lo sappiamo
a rischio
non ci posso credere ragazzi sono
riuscita a rientrare in casa per un pelo
gremirà proprio dietro alla porta
eccole lì è scomparso e viva questa è
bella luna rossa non so se si vede molto
bene abbiamo vinto anche questo
challenge assieme se volete un altro
campeggio horror da brividi con un altro
personaggio
lasciate un bel mi piace questo video se
questo video raggiunto i 35 mila mi
piace il prossimo campeggio sarà con un
personaggio scelto da voi nei commenti
e ora vi lascio qua 4 caselli mese puoi
cliccar vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione